B
H
Muslims say the darnest things. Okay.
[music]
>> Um what what are your thoughts? Is Allah
a father in any sense?
>> Metaphorically you can say so.
>> Metaphorically is in in what way?
metaphorically how
>> like in the sense of a father being a a
source, a guidance and a protector.
Okay.
>> In that type of sense.
>> Okay. Cool. So could we say that Allah
is also metaphorically a mother? You
know
>> Mhm. You can say that. Yeah.
>> Can you can you also say that
metaphorically that Allah is a chair in
the in the way that chairs offer you
support and they offer you a foundation
and Allah he supports you. He's your
foundation. Can you say metaphorically
Allah is a chair too
>> in the support way? I mean you as long
as metaphorically you not worship in a
chair why not [laughter]
>> why not like why not
>> is there a correct sense in which Allah
begat Jesus
>> yeah like if beget just means create
then and there's no essence none of that
bro then yeah we' accept that meaning
>> Allah is the one who begat Jesus that's
what you're saying is Allah the father
>> I would say so the
>> Allah is the father of Jesus
>> no Allah is the father of of all things
like he is the Okay, we got authority.
>> Can it also be said then that Allah is
the mother of all things too.
>> Then equally it it could be assumed. It
could be assumed.
>> All right. Allah is a father and mother.
>> So So just to be clear, you can pray to
Jesus.
>> Yes, we can pray to Jesus because he's
our beloved prophet. So there's nothing
wrong with that.
>> Why don't you guys follow Jesus, man?
>> I need not follow him.
>> Oh, you don't need to follow him. Okay.
>> I think you're afraid to objectively
prove my revelation is authentic. You're
right. I am I am objectively proving it
from your book.
>> That's not objective. THAT'S
>> OH. OH, THANK OH, THANK YOU. SO, your
So, your your book is Your book is
subjective. It's not objective truth.
>> No. No. Again, from your book.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Say Say it again. No,
say it again. Your book Your book, The
Quran, is not an objective truth. Is
that correct?
>> For you, for you. [laughter]
>> So, Prophet Muhammad corrected these
beliefs of the past.
>> So, he corrected Jesus.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. So Muhammad Muhammad came Jesus in
the past had a incorrect view of God and
Muhammad came and corrected Jesus's view
of God. Is that right?
>> Can we Yes. I'm going to say yes. But
can I say something? Can I Can I ask
you?
>> Do you agree that Jesus creates life
like Allah did?
>> Well, he he created life in his own
respect. Yeah.
>> He created life just like Allah did.
Right. Allah made Adam. Jesus made the
bird. Allah made Adam from clay and
breathed into him the spirit of life.
Jesus made the bird from clay and
breathed into it the spirit of life. So
just like how Allah created Adam, Jesus
created the bird, right?
>> Mhm.
>> So Jesus created life, gave life, and
you're saying that he's not God. How
many creators do you have then?
>> Okay, man. The way trying to put the
argument, man, it's only one God, but
and two creators.
>> Says that Muhammad is the final
messenger,
>> right? And prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he comes forth in this
book and testifies that he did not say
those words that those were imputed upon
him and that he testified of the coming
of the Messiah or the prophet John peace
be upon him.
>> You said that they corrupted the Quran
to make it seem like there's not going
to be another relation coming.
>> All the pictures have been corrupted.
Yes.
>> Even the Quran.
>> Allah informs us in this book. Yes. That
the Quran was altered.
>> Wait, wait, wait. It's respect. Wait,
wait. It's respectful to do what?
>> To burn the Quran to get rid of it. The
words of Allah
are not disrespectful.
>> Technically, you can say Jesus gave
life, but it was through the power of
Allah.
>> No worries. How many creators do you
have now? Now that Jesus received power
and created a bird from clay and
breathed life into it, how many creators
do you have now of life?
>> Oh, there's another. Yes.
>> So, how many?
>> A second one.
>> So, there's a second creator next to
Allah. So,
how are you guys monotheists again?
There's a sahi adith that talks about
the sun setting in murky water.
>> Prove to me that the verse was not meant
to be allegorical and prove to me that
the sun cannot set in water.
>> Wait, prove to you that the sun can't
set in water?
>> Yes, prove it to me.
>> So, you believe that the sun can set in
water?
>> I believe in miracles. I believe that
Allah can do supernatural things. This
>> isn't a supernatural phenomenon. This is
a natural phenomenon that Muhammad is
saying. He's saying that naturally the
sun sets when it's setting. It sets in
murky water, not it can't. Prove to me
it can't.
>> Prove to you it can't.
>> Yes. Prove it.
>> Can you prove to me that I don't have a
pink elephant under my desk right now?
>> Brother, you're not an honest person.
>> Thanks for coming, man.
>> Believe in what I have sent down. What
is that?
>> The Quran.
>> What is the Quran doing?
>> It is confirming itself.
But the Quran, [laughter]
okay, I can't take care, bro.
>> Yeah, absolutely. In the seventh
century, at the time of Muhammad, Allah,
sorry, who's supposedly revealing this
Quran, he's saying to those Jews, why
are you taking these things in part?
That's bad. You're going to go to hell.
You need to take it in full in the
seventh century. What was that mean
about the Torah? It means that they
should believe it even though it is
corrupted because obviously
>> what
>> so Allah wants them to believe in the
corrupts
>> in the corrupted book.
>> You believe that Islam is reliable?
>> I do think so. Yes.
>> Do you believe that a religion that has
corrupted scripture is reliable?
>> No.
>> We have the Torah, the Zabor, the
Psalms.
>> Mhm.
>> And the Injil, the Gospel.
>> Yes.
>> All three of these scriptures are
Islamic scriptures.
>> And these Islamic scriptures got
corrupted.
>> Yes. So therefore Islam is unreliable
because it has corrupted texts.
>> I would say the religion is unreliable,
right? But the word of God is reliable,
right? But humans are not. So
>> So Islam, Islam is unreliable. God is
reliable.
>> Yes.
>> Answering you by
>> can someone have all authority in heaven
and on earth besides Allah? Yes or no?
>> Yes, it can.
>> Who is it? So tell us, teach us who is
speaking. Who's the speaker in this
verse?
>> Who's the speaker?
>> Who's saying?
>> I I don't know. Okay,
>> dude. What are you talking about?
[laughter] Okay. Who Who's addressing
Muhammad in the Quran?
>> Yeah. Who Who says Muhammad? Oh, you're
a great
>> How am I How am I How am I supposed to
know? Wait, what? You don't know who is
speaking in the Quran?
>> Leave.
>> Is it possible that the speaker is
wrong? Is that what you're trying to
say? Is the speaker wrong? Because
you're trying to take it away from
Allah. So, is it possible?
>> So, are the words true? Let's let's
start with that. Are the words true? Are
the words true? Why do they come to you
for judgment when they have the Torah?
Because it has the judgment of Allah.
Are those words true?
>> Uh these are uh words these are words of
question. These words do not confirm
anything.
>> Are they are they tr are they is it true
to say that the Torah has the judgment
of Allah?
>> Yeah. Is it true?
>> Is that true?
>> No, it's it's not true. It's it's a
question. It's not an answer.
>> Yeah. And then and then again verse
verse 41. It's Allah. It's clearly Allah
saying, "Oh apostle." And he just
continues talking. In verse 42, he
continues talking to Muhammad. In verse
43, he continues talking to Muhammad. So
if you say this is actually someone
else, just tell us who. Is it Bob? Is it
Iben Massud? Who Who's talking?
>> It must be It must be one of the
companions. [laughter]
>> Which companion? Which companion? Which
companions? Which companions words are
put into the Quran without identifying
that it's a companion? And it sounds
just like it's uh it's Allah speaking.
Was wait was Jesus wrong when he said
that he's the son of God.
>> He isn't wrong but it's something that
before Islam the relation
>> the Quran is the angel.
>> The Quran is the good news. Yes.
>> Is the Quran the angel?
>> Yes. Read it.
>> I think Okay. Can God Can God have
flaws?
>> Well, he's all able, right?
>> He's all able. Is he Can he have flaws
though?
>> If he's all able, he can have anything.
>> Can he have flaws? Can he can he have
flaws and be imp? No, this is according
to you
>> because he's he's hold me. This is
another one. So Allah can have flaws.
>> Do you disagree that Jesus is for all
mankind?
>> That he is for all of mankind.
>> Mhm.
>> In what sense?
>> In the sense that it's be that he he and
his mission mission his message the
salvation he brings is for all mankind.
>> Um are you saying that on Islamic belief
or on the Christian believe? cuz he
didn't bring any salvation according to
us. But okay,
>> wait. Say, say that again.
>> He didn't bring any salvation according
to Islam.
>> Do you do you believe that Muhammad
brought salvation?
>> Did Muhammad?
>> No, I don't think he brings salvation. I
just think he preaches been told to him.
>> Nice. Nice. Nice.
>> It just said that Quranic material
whether they're whole copies or
fragments be burned. So Qurans, whole
copies of Qurans were burned. What are
you talking about? Yeah. What? Yeah. So,
what a man burnt was extra stuff that
was added.
>> Was it Quran? Was it Qurans?
>> No. No. No. It wasn't It wasn't Quran.
>> All right. So, it says it says Quranic
materials. Whole copies of Quranic
materials. What are whole copies of
Quranic materials? Is that is that not
Quran?
>> No, it's not. Talk about the Quran. The
Quran got banned. It's the stuff that
was added into
>> I got you. Thanks for coming. I I got
you. I got you. I got you. Thanks for
coming. Thanks for coming. Did Jesus
come into existence at any point in
time?
>> If you did exist before the ages,
>> right? Ready? If you mean by did he come
into existence, was he created out of
nothing? No. Was he in the father prior
to being begotten and brought forth?
Yes. That's what the early Christians
believe.
>> That means that he always exist.
>> So Jesus is most high in in the sense
that in
>> all other things except the father.
>> Is uh is Jesus Yahweh? Jesus is Yahweh
in the lesser sense. Yeah.
>> Jesus is Yahweh [laughter]
in the lesser sense. Like for example,
if I were to say that I'm mentioned in
the Quran, I'm I'm when it when it
mentions the seal of the prophets,
that's me. It's talking about Avery.
Will I need a scriptural basis to back
up what I'm saying?
>> Well, the thing is God um can prove
someone's a prophet by many ways, not
just prophecy. For example, miracle.
>> That's not what I asked. I simply asked,
would I need do so? So, I wouldn't need
a a biblical or not biblical but a
scriptural basis to claim what I'm
claiming about being the seal of the me
of the prophets?
>> No.
>> If if if we're going based on the text,
I have a valid claim based on the text,
right?
>> Um, sure.
>> What's one time three?
>> What is one to the third power?
[laughter]
>> What's one time three? What's one time
three?
>> Three. What's one to the third power?
>> All right, This is crazy.
>> What's one to the third power?
>> It's three, man. One to the third one to
the third power is three.
>> Yes. As as you said.
>> So either Jesus is lying and he doesn't
send him and he's a liar or he's telling
the truth and he does send the comforter
who you say is Muhammad
>> or maybe I I think that that it's with
the authorization of God that
>> No worries. So Allah is a partner has a
partner with Jesus and so Jesus you
believe Jesus is the one who sent
Muhammad.
>> Yeah. So it says Jesus went about all
Galilee teaching preaching the gospel of
the kingdom. That's the angel.
>> I'm sorry. Where was he at?
>> What? Matthew 4:23.
>> No, no, I know the verse, but where did
it say Jesus was preaching at?
>> Galilei.
>> Okay. [laughter] Nice. All right.
>> Is it a sin to influence someone else to
sin?
>> The only one who can do this other than
Satan is God. And God cannot sin. So no,
it's not a sin if
>> Got it. So just so just be clear, it is
not a sin to influence others to sin.
Got it. So I so I should appeal to a
scholar of today rather than Allah.
>> What? No, you're not Muslim. So of
course you are.
>> But even even as a Christian, as a
Christian, should I appeal to someone
else other than Allah?
>> I expect you to do that cuz you're not a
Muslim.
>> Should I?
>> Of course you should. Of course you
should. You logic. You especially you
should.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> No, no, no, no, no. You should logic.
>> And you're you're saying that I should.
It it's a good thing I ought to go to
somebody else, appeal to somebody else
instead of what Allah says. Should I go
with the scholars or should I go with?
>> Yes, go with the scholars. Go with the
scholars, man. Go with the scholars.
>> So, all right. So, we all heard it here
first, guys. We should always go with
the scholars rather than going with
Allah. The scholars are right over the
over Allah. Is that right?
>> Telling about you.
>> No, don't don't say don't ask
forgiveness now and don't seek refuge
from Satan. He's already got you. Yes.
Thera, the
>> all the Quran. That's the Quran. And the
Torah is the Quran.
>> Pay attention. Those are not. Those are
all Allah's scriptures. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> All right. And they all got corrupted.
>> Not corrupted. They got the virus. And
now we have they caught a virus.
>> They You got to write that down.
>> The Torah, the gospel, and the I mean
the Torah, the Psalms, and the Gospel,
they weren't corrupted. They caught a
virus. [laughter]
>> Would you f Is your religion trustworthy
if it contained corrupted scripture?
>> Why not? Yes.
>> No. House of Israel doesn't mean
Israelite.
>> Can you give me an example where someone
comes from the house of Israel and is
not an Israelite?
>> Yes. You know the house of Israel is 12
tribes of Jacob. Yes.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, is Ishmael not a is not a
tribe of Jacob?
>> No, brother.
>> Is not?
>> No. What will Allah do to you if you
followed his commands perfectly? What
would he do to you?
>> No, he didn't say follow my command
perfectly. He said that if you were not
to commit sin.
>> Now, now, now we now we don't know if
following Allah's commands means that
you don't sin. He never said if you
follow his commands perfectly. He just
said if you don't sin. So, you can still
follow Allah's command and sin when you
follow it. Can you claim to be the first
and the last and you're and you're still
a Muslim? You're you're not committing
sh.
>> Yeah, it depends in context. Got
>> Would you would you agree with me that
there's a big difference between Allah
doing something and Muhammad doing
something?
>> No.
>> Okay. I you know
>> that's not a big difference. Like the
difference
>> the word ayah can mean actual revelation
from God. It can also mean like I got
some inspiration from seeing a cat, you
know, uh lick its kitten. Like do you
have any manuscript in existence of that
inje?
>> Yes.
>> Wait. Yes. You have a manuscript of it?
>> Well, if you mean by a manuscript, you
mean a a physical copy?
>> Yes. That's what a manuscript is. A
handwritten copy.
>> That's that's what I'll let John answer
this and then we got to move forward.
>> That that's what's in the hadith, David.
Not the people. I don't say the people
of the gospel. Let's clarify the
is there a copy of this Torah anywhere
that you're aware of?
No.
>> Okay. So, there's no copy of this Torah.
Uh when did So, it was lost by the time
of Jesus.
>> Uh it's small parchments. If you see my
presentation, there was still a
believing group who still had parts of
it hidden in a horn around their neck,
you know, very small parts. Yeah.
>> And and do you do you have these? Do you
have these parts?
>> No, we have authentic hadith, which is
inspiration from God. What's the David?
If you don't know by now, maybe the
audience could tell you. It's a book
sent down from Allah to Jesus. It It's
an oral book, an audio book a bit like
what we have on have on Amazon now.
>> Is Jesus the word as a Muslim? As a
Muslim, do you believe Jesus is the word
of Allah?
>> Oh, I'm the prophet is the word of
Allah.
>> You said that all you said that all the
prophets are the word of Allah.
>> No. We as all of us, we Allah said to us
be and we were to be.
>> So you're saying that you're saying that
we all are the word of Allah.
>> Of course. When Allah says if he wanted
to take a son he could, you're saying he
actually can't.
>> According to the interpretation, yeah.
>> So Allah's lying.
>> No, he's not. It's just the language
that's used.
>> No. Yeah. According according to the
language he's using, he affirms that he
could have a son if he wanted one.
According to that scholarly according to
that I know according to the scholarly
interpretation or that side of scholarly
interpretation
>> they're saying well what Allah is saying
is the opposite of what he just said
that when he says if he wanted to have a
son he could what he really means is is
that it's impossible if he
>> yeah so he's basically outlining the
claims of the kufur
>> it's beautiful you believe that God is
is good right that he's had no evil
within him
>> uh God chooses to be good
>> so does he have evil in in him
>> if he chooses he could I'm not saying he
>> okay
>> he hasn't done anything wrong he's
innocent you unal alive that man you
don't let him go to heaven you
completely wipe him out from existence
would that be would that be good or evil
to do
>> I just said it's good
>> okay this is sah Muslim 2749 by him in
whose hand is my life this is Muhammad
speaking by him in whose hand is my life
if you were not to commit sin if you did
not sin obeyed Allah perfectly loved him
perfectly believed in him, would he
reward you? Nah. It says Allah would
sweep you out of existence. Which one
did Allah say eternally? Cuz the Quran
is supposed to be Allah's eternal word
for word speech. So which one did he
say? Did Allah say that he's the king of
the day of judgment? Or did he say that
he's the master of the day of judgment?
>> He is the owner of day of judgment.
>> So not the king.
>> So Allah So Allah is not a king. Allah
is not Allah is above that.
>> Uh Muzzi's super chatting an argument.
Numbers 23:19. Jesus says Jesus says I
am not a man nor a son of man. So wait
just to be clear. So you're saying that
Jesus is speaking in numbers 23.
So you're saying that Jesus is God?
[laughter]
>> So the so the unitarians that say Jesus
is the son of God and is a god in a
lesser sense they're they got the truth
and are going to go to heaven according
to Islam.
>> Yeah. You're saying that Allah allowed
his scriptures to be corrupted for the
wisdom of focusing on the Quran more
than the previous. So the Quran would
have been would not have been the hot
topic and and the Quran would have been
a little jealous of the Torah and Gospel
and Psalms. So Allah's like, "Hey,
you're going to we're going to make you
the star. And to make you the star, I'm
going to have to allow my own words in
revelation to be tampered with and
degraded so that you can stand out.
That's you're you're saying that's
Allah's wisdom.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Well, yeah. Your question is uh if it
goes against Jesus, it's false, right?
If a religion
>> Yes. goes against
>> your religion goes against the religion
of Jesus, that religion is false, right?
Do you agree with that?
>> Yeah. Well, there well then if we're
assuming the religion of Jesus is from
>> Do you agree with that or not?
>> Well, no.
>> I angels don't identify themselves as
God. But there's one particular angel,
one particular messenger that identifies
himself as being God, specifically being
Yahweh. And so, you're okay with that?
That angels can identify themselves as
Allah?
>> Yeah. Because God is obviously using
them as a
>> Okay. But the the problem that the
Muslim believe that Jesus he is Isa.
That's not
>> Say that again.
>> Muslim believe. Well, they believe
they're confused.
>> Huh? They think Jesus is Isa the son of
Miriam.
>> And is that true?
>> No, it's not true.
>> By the way, are you Muslim?
>> Yes, I am.
>> What? Can't make this up.
Never go full Muslim.